[Música]
a
el centro europeo de control de
enfermedades ha colocado a prácticamente
toda europa en rojo es decir los números
de contagios es muy alto y también el
número de tests positivos por lo tanto
todos los viajeros que provengan de
zonas rojas deberán estar con sujetos
viena test o cuarentenas obligatorias
uno de esos países en rojo es bélgica
que a pesar de que poco a poco en las
últimas semanas se han ido bajando el
número de contagios aún así sigue siendo
muy alto de hecho las restricciones como
el toque de queda y el cierre de la
hostelería aún se mantiene de hecho no
se descarta que este cierre se mantenga
también durante las vacaciones de
navidad porque es en espacios cerrados
con mucha gente y también con poca
ventilación que hace que se propague el
virus con mucha más facilidad con un
clima tan lluvioso y tan frío como el de
bélgica los expertos del país advierten
que no se puede abrir excesivamente
rápido este sector o de lo contrario los
rebrotes pueden volver a multiplicarse
[Música]
es un hecho la circulación del coi 19
está disminuyendo en francia- como
prueba el número de nuevos contagios si
la semana pasada hablábamos de récord
diario de 60 mil este lunes hubo apenas
9.000 lo mismo el porcentaje de
positivos estamos lejos muy por debajo
del 20% de comienzos de noviembre así lo
confirmó el portavoz del gobierno tras
salir hoy de un consejo de defensa sin
embargo dijo que la guerra contra la
pandemia está lejos de haber terminado
por lo mismo los franceses esperan
ansiosos el discurso que debe dar la
próxima semana el presidente matrón
donde muchos creen va a presentar su
estrategia de desconfía miento
básicamente apertura de comercios no
esenciales mezclados con un toque de
queda sin embargo ayer audicionado por
la asamblea nacional del primer ministro
jan caster reconocía que las
restricciones seguirán más allá del 1 de
diciembre la fecha de fin del segundo
confinamiento a largo plazo el gobierno
planea una estrategia de inmunización de
la población con vacunaciones masivas a
partir del próximo año
[Música]
actualmente alrededor del 90% de los
distritos alemanes son considerados
zonas rojas por su muy alta incidencia
en el número de casos de coronavirus y
esto se suma que las autoridades en este
país ya reconocieron que les resulta
imposible rastrear el origen de la
mayoría de los casos dos retos enormes
para alemania en esta segunda ola de
coronavirus que en muchos aspectos está
resultando incluso más problemática que
la primera los principales objetivos de
las autoridades son por un lado reducir
esos muy altos números de coronavirus de
ahí ya hayan impuesto una serie de
restricciones que ha sido descrita aquí
como un lock down parcial hasta finales
del mes de noviembre y por el otro lado
evitar que el sistema de salud se vaya a
ver abrumado el sistema de salud todavía
puede responder a los nuevos casos de
coronavirus y se estima que alrededor
del 20 por ciento de las camas de
cuidados intensivos siguen disponibles
pero las autoridades han indicado que si
los números siguen creciendo de la
manera como se ha visto en las últimas
semanas el sistema de salud muy pronto
podría llegar a su límite
[Música]